[Musique]
ils sont venus dire non on passe
vaccinal à Paris le cortège s'était
lancé en milieu d'après-midi de la place
du Palais Royal à l'appel de Florian
Philippot les Français se réveille et se
lève qui sait pas insulter en l'espèce
de dingue qui est à la tête de l'État
qui s'est permis d'avoir les combos
orduriers de division d'apparten contre
son propre peuple les sondages décollent
pas les tentatives de rassemblement font
long feu j'adore comme Hidalgo autobera
sur une audim la gauche n'est pas loin
du naufrage et vous jetez le journal
c'est pas bien ça pour vos collègues
j'ai envie de l'emmerder moi tout
simplement il a un grave mépris pour les
Français je trouve et surtout pour les
noms vaccinés mais tout ça se réglera
aux urnes c'est aussi ce que demande le
peuple de gauche ne jetez pas mon
affiche en pierre mais mais si vous
permettez vous dites réunir la France
d'abord il faut que vous réunissiez la
gauche on l'emmerde
qu'on l'emmer parce que son vaccin c'est
pas un vaccin c'est une expérience je
proclame que j'accepte les règles de la
primaire populaire
je prends et j'accepte le risque de la
démocratie quand c'est non c'est non
donc vous ne participez pas à la maison
vous avez peur ou pas mais non je suis
primaire citoyenne la primaire des
écologistes Christiane Taubira fait le
choix elle l'annonce d'être candidate et
risque d'être une candidate de plus ce
qui compte pour les Français c'est qu'il
puisse avoir le choix avec des
programmes différents je ne connais pas
son programme
moins de 95 jours avant une élection
présidentielle le temps est passé de
faire des congrès il faut avoir à
proposer au pays si on veut
raisonnablement gagner et ne pas croire
que la France serait une sorte de cour
de récréation où on est entre copains
sur Twitter quelqu'un qui s'appelle
Guillaume TC qui vous a croisé avec
Nicolas Sarkozy ça donne ça quand tu
reviens de la cave mais que tu n'as pas
trouvé le kärcher faut dire pour Valérie
Pécresse Guillaume Pelletier le député
LR du Loir-et-Cher annonce rejoindre
Éric Zemmour il sera même porte-parole
du parti reconquête le seul candidat
fidèle aux valeurs du RPR
le seul candidat capable de battre
Emmanuel Macron parce que capable de
rassembler tous les électeurs de droite
le seul candidat fondamentalement
courageux et lucides sur l’état de la
société française j'ai décidé de
soutenir
Eric Zemmour Éric Zemmour et le complice
de l'examen puisque il veut s'allier
avec l'extrême droite c'est ça et pour
être chez vous
Eric Zemmour moi je pourrais être non
parce qu'il veut je vais le répéter une
troisième fois au cas où personne
n'aurait compris
ça m'étonne pas de lui
il aura caché toutes les cases il aura
fait tous les mouvements politiques
notre ami Guillaume vous poussez alors
peut-être pas vous directement mais dans
le parti certains maires et l'air de lui
donner parrainage estimons cela
peut-être que s'il était candidat il a
fait virer Marine Le Pen mais d'abord
d'abord les mères sont des citoyens
éclairés et avisés donc c'est pas des
personnes à qui on donne des
instructions
est-ce qu'il serait sanctionné
en tout cas il n'appartiendrait plus de
fait aux républicains heureusement la
droite en France c'est pas ça la droite
en France c'est pas à ramasser de
fasciste prêt à tout moment à courir
derrière le dernier énergumène qui
raconte n'importe quoi le cadre donc
pour vous est-ce que c'est le cas moi je
crois que c'est de la comédie au Brésil
au moins cette mort et trois disparu
après une chute de rocher dans un lac
touristique si tu as un pont de falaise
qui s'est décroché sur des bateaux qui
naviguaient dans ce canyon très
touristique quel est votre reine
je suggère que la polygamie soit
accessible